in this situation mike's grab
my hand i'm going to move off to a 45
degree angle
all i care techniques begins by getting
offline it's the most important thing we
do
so i'll like just like all the other
techniques first thing i do is get off
this 45 degree angle
as i do that my hand's going to come up
in front of my face
now if i were to move this violently and
he didn't have a really great grip or he
wasn't flowing with me
i could probably pull it out here but he
sticks right with me
i then grab his hand isolating it and i
pop my hand the rest of the way free
what i want to do is turn the thin part
of my forearm towards the weak part of
his grip
and pop my hand down from here i'm going
to do the next logical thing
i'm going to try and hit him in the face
but he has a block for this i'm then
going to bind both of his arms together
so this is the juju the figure 10.
i'm crossing his arms like this i want
the inside of one elbow to touch the
inside of the other elbow
as i roll them together from this
position i'm going to start to break
mike's balance
step behind him so he can't step and
bring him down from here i'm going to
pull both of his arms across his chest
as tight as i can
and drop my shin on top of my my back
hand now
comes up and controls the top and i
raise up from here i could draw a weapon
or use my cell phone whatever it is i
need to do from this position
one more time to speed
yeah captain